[Música]
hola bienvenido a Francia en foco 2022
fue un año de cambios en el panorama
político francés en la elección
presidencial de abril Emanuel macron
aseguró su reelección una señal de
estabilidad sin embargo en las
legislativas de junio su partido perdió
la mayoría aquí en la asamblea nacional
y un gran número de asientos se
concentró en ambos extremos del espectro
político en el programa de hoy veremos
las causas de estas reconfiguración del
Poder y sus consecuencias para la
democracia y para los franceses
estamos en la entrada del hemiciclo un
salón de 577 asientos donde se debaten
las propuestas de leyes del gobierno y
se llevan a votación antes de pasar al
senado como el partido en el poder no
tiene la mayoría aquí pues necesita del
apoyo de otras agrupaciones políticas
para validar esos textos un presidente y
una primera ministra sin apoyo
mayoritario en la asamblea nacional no
es algo inédito en la República francesa
pero sí requiere de un despliegue de
habilidades para la concertación y la
negociación
un desafío a la gobernabilidad anunciado
desde la misma noche de la elección
presidencial
[Aplausos]
sé que muchos de nuestros compatriotas
votaron Hoy por mí no Para apoyar mis
ideas sino para bloquear al extrema
derecha y quiero decirles aquí que soy
consciente de que ese voto es una
obligación para los próximos años
[Aplausos]
después de esta lección presidencial una
gran recomposición política se abre
camino en el país el partido no está
decidido porque en algunas semanas se
realizarán las elecciones legislativas
los franceses que me elijan Primer
Ministro para ello les pido elegir una
mayoría de diputados de Francis sumisa
será la tercera vuelta de la elección
presidencial
ningún partido alcanzó la mayoría
absoluta en el parlamento pero los
comicios legislativos sellaron el
vaticinado ascenso de la izquierda unida
en la coalición lupés y del partido de
ultraderecha reagrupación nacional como
las fuerzas de oposición dominantes en
el hemiciclo ambas formaciones políticas
volcarían el peso de ese resultado en un
objetivo acabar con el gobierno de
Elizabeth y llegar al poder ante esa
amenaza el presidente Emmanuel lanzó
anzuelos a sus oponentes con intereses
más cercanos para proponerles una
coalición pero su maniobra fracasó
esta situación constituye un riesgo para
nuestro país en vista de los desafíos
que debemos afrontar tanto a Escala
Nacional como internacional
para avanzar con sus proyectos de ley y
romper con lo que su gobierno considera
como bloqueos de sus adversarios La
Premier se ha visto forzada a recurrir a
una controversial herramienta el
artículo 49 inciso 3 de la Constitución
que sea le otorga el ejecutivo el
derecho de aprobar los textos sin
votación ni concertación con el resto de
partidos políticos la reacción de sus
oponentes no se ha hecho esperar cada
vez que el gobierno usa esa prerrogativa
se ha encontrado con una respectiva
moción de censura
señora primera ministra usted es en esa
función una anomalía democrática se
acabó el tiempo en que se consideraba la
democracia como un accesorio A
diferencia de una postura esta moción de
censura sirve para desenmascarar
imposturas
el 49.3 no es una manera sosegada de
gestión del país es un procedimiento que
por su brutalidad simbólica debe ser
utilizado de forma excepcional su
utilización masiva que se promete hacer
testimonio de la debilidad del poder una
inaptitud para jugar el juego
democrático
hasta el momento las mociones de censura
no han recibido la cantidad de votos
necesarios para derrocar al gobierno
Pero si así ocurriera El Ejecutivo aún
tendría herramientas para desbloquear
ese eventual impass político según el
presidente macron entre ellas están los
referendos pero también la disolución de
la asamblea algo que según sus propias
palabras no dudará en hacer si Su
autoridad se ve amenazada en un
escenario de disolución se convocarían
nuevas elecciones legislativas sin
embargo las encuestas indican que el
partido oficialista volvería a tener la
mayoría relativa y cambiaría poco la
distribución del poder en la cámara baja
el riesgo de esa maniobra sería una vez
más el fortalecimiento de los partidos
extremistas
la apatía de los electores hacia los
partidos políticos tradicionales se vio
reflejada en los resultados de la más
reciente contienda legislativa las
agrupaciones políticas más cercanas a
los extremos fueron las grandes
ganadoras de esas elecciones a la
asamblea nacional France 24 conversó con
representantes de esos partidos para
conocer las estrategias políticas que
han catalizado su ascenso en esta
legislatura
una furgoneta estacionada en una esquina
del Distrito 13 de París es la manera en
que el diputado Franco chileno Rodrigo
Arenas del partido de izquierda a la
Francia en sumisa encontró para
acercarse a sus electores en
contraposición a un gobierno alejado de
los votantes como repitieron sin cese
durante la campaña de las legislativas
me doy cuenta que con la ruptura
democrática que está atravesando Francia
es difícil en particular para la
ciudadanía que talama alejada de la
instituciones de venir hacia una persona
que un diputado que encarga una función
a veces y muchas veces muy lejanas de
ellos
vivienda impuestos pero también preocupa
a los electores el uso reiterado que
está haciendo el gobierno de Manuel
macron del artículo 49-3 que permite al
ejecutivo aprobar proyectos de ley sin
consultar a los diputados
como respuesta la nupes el bloque de
izquierda que es hoy el mayor grupo
opositor y el que pertenece la Francia
en sumisa presentó varias mociones de
censura al gobierno Arenas decidió ir
más lejos y ponerse en huelga
por primera vez un diputado se puso en
huelga Por qué Porque yo te defendiendo
el parlamento Estoy defendiendo por el
legislativo y que El Ejecutivo no puede
dominar de tan fuertemente el
legislativo ya no es posible por ejemplo
que el primer presupuesto del estado que
es la educación no haya sido debatido
conversado y votado en la asamblea la
misma estrategia del lado opuesto del
espectro político en este mercado de la
región de laloira Matilde París diputado
del partido de extrema derecha
agrupación nacional ha instalado su
propia casa rodante como oficina está la
cuestión muy fuerte de los
desplazamientos en una circunscripción
rural como la mía que es muy extensa
donde el precio del combustible puede
ser un impedimento para reunirse con su
diputado en su permanencia fija en parte
de la circunscripción Entonces es un
verdadero medio para recuperar la
cercanía con los ciudadanos y también
recrear un vínculo de confianza
mostrando que efectivamente no es solo
el momento de las elecciones sino que
como diputada Yo estoy con ellos durante
todo mi mandato desde la presidenciales
y las posteriores legislativas en que
consiguió 89 diputados en rn está en una
campaña de normalización evitando los
discursos más radicales y mostrándose
como un partido que busca compromisos y
que escucha a los sectores más populares
en contraposición al gobierno y sus
diputados
ayer por ejemplo el gobierno y sus
diputados obstruyeron el debate sobre la
reincorporación del personal médico
suspendido por no vacunarse es
vergonzoso pues poco antes de que se
suspendiera la sesión a las 8 de la
noche presentaron unas 200 enmiendas
cuando había apenas una veintena de
debatir hoy todos los países vecinos han
reintegrado al personal médico y estamos
en una crisis todo el mundo sabe que en
los servicios pediá hay una epidemia de
bronquiolitis con niños que no pueden
ser atendidos incluso recién nacidos
en su crítica al gobierno y acercamiento
a las clases populares ambos extremos se
tocan peligrosamente al punto de que la
moción de censura de la izquierda que
tuvo mejor resultado fue aquella que fue
apoyada por la extrema derecha
ni Matilde ni Rodrigo dicen temera La
amenaza de una disolución de la asamblea
esbozada por el presidente Manuel macron
pero las encuestas vaticinan que en caso
de nuevas legislativas el único partido
que saldría reforzado sería el de marine
leppen
la relación entre los políticos
franceses y sus electores ha cambiado
han desaparecido barreras Como los
prejuicios con respecto a la edad pero
también se han vuelto comunes ideas
antes consideradas como de extremo vamos
a profundizar en este aspecto con
nuestro invitado de hoy él es Pascal Duo
politólogo e investigador del instituto
azul de París un tanque pensante francés
Gracias Pascal por estar con nosotros
hoy en Francia enfoque Muchas gracias Es
un gusto Me gustaría comenzar
preguntándole este rompecabezas que
tiene en estos momentos el gobierno se
debe al cambio de fuerzas que ha
ocurrido en la asamblea nacional sin
embargo estos productos de elecciones
completamente constitucionales estamos
en presencia de más o menos democracia
en el país No creo que todo eso es
el resultado de de un proceso de un
proceso democrático de un proceso social
que estamos enfrentados todos pero en
particular en Francia estamos en un país
democrático que viven democracia Pero
obviamente la democracia cambia
evoluciona se adapta el camino está la
democracia lo permite Pero qué
condiciones tienen que existir para que
en las próximas elecciones
presidenciales llegue al Eliseo un
representante de Estas ideas extremistas
todo es económico
el tema central queda la economía que
queda en la bolsa de cada uno al final
del mes para poder vivir con su familia
de manera decente y por lo menos
nutrirse todos los días temas societales
sociales que llevan sobre la coherencia
de la nación es decir ese es esa esa
percepción de una comunitarización de de
Francia creo que esos son dos Pilares
céntricos
si seguimos con la idea de una
comunitarización de una presión
diría
ligada a la noción de
islamismo ahí puede puede llegar
definitivamente
un representante de partidos más
extremistas Muchísimas gracias Pascal
por recibirnos en su estudio y también
adentrarnos en estos temas de política
francesa tan apasionantes un gran gusto
Muchas gracias Luis Miguel
hasta aquí esta edición de Francia
enfoca donde hemos intentado tomarle el
pulso a la democracia francesa en este
año electoral nos encuentra cada semana
en la señal de televisión de France 24 y
en nuestras redes sociales hasta la
próxima
[Música]